gardez en route
on se parle des serres à une belle une
belle bûche royal on a acheté également
un beau chapeau pour le principal et
puis puydupin du pain bio donc un pain
pas normal complet et puis
un appel singles voilà au plus près du
repas de réveillon les commerçants du
marché du quai du roi orléans ont décidé
de s'installer exceptionnellement ce 24
décembre ses fonctions du calendrier
quand vous voyez le jour de noël le jour
de l'an qui tombe le mardi on fait ses
courses samedi ça va bien se garder la
salade jusqu'à lundi soir
donc l'idée nous est venue d'organiser
un marché qui tombe le 24 avec beaucoup
de travail déjà ces derniers jours ces
professionnels des métiers de bouche
étaient présents alors et alto ce matin
avec peu de publicité la fréquentation
n'a pas été importante et seuls les
produits de fête ont tiré leur épingle
du jeu
volailles fruits de mer et pâtisseries
on a énormément de commandes déjà et
c'est bien parce que tout le monde ne
peut pas venir le samedi parce qu'il ya
des gens qui travaillent donc c'est moi
je dis que le lundi c'est bien le lundi
de fête pour noël c'est très bien eh ben
ça permet de faire les courses qu'on n'a
pas eu le temps de faire avant et comme
je savais qu'il était là ce matin mon
noël c'est très pratique parce que j'en
ai sûr d'avoir des produits de qualité
frais et donc voilà on a fait exprès de
venir ce jour là pour comprendre nos
produits on est on les a réservé et puis
on les a pris une journée de chiffre
d'affaires supplémentaire payée au prix
fort ce soir par les commerçants ça fait
quelques jours qu'on tarde pas donc on
va peut-être un petit peu se mettant au
repos mais grâce à demain midi